[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot this
is episode 2.5 I'm like my hearty and
I'm Joe Decker and last week we
published an episode of our opinion
editorial show of reboot about Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild we titled it
why Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
is the open-world game we need we talked
about how all the new things does for
this other series for Nintendo but also
it came along at a time when I think a
lot of us are getting tired of open
world games yeah revenue heaven was
great but you haven't seen it yet you
should probably watch that before you
watch this yeah I was gonna make a lot
of sense right as usual in our off week
we ran to any QA about the past episode
and like answering more questions we
might not have gone to in the video and
then we're going to tease our next
episode which we kind of just yesterday
figured out what we want to do so we'll
be writing that over the weekend Jake
and I be working on that next week but
anyway yeah we we played breast of the
wild a fair amount of it came out so
then the more we played it we were
trying to figure out what we wanted to
do with it cuz we knew it was kind of a
big deal to say the least
and then we ended up want to talk about
I came along at the time it did why it
helps it set a new benchmark for
open-world games for people people
mention The Witcher 3 and what like I
said that it's open-world overshadows
the witcher 3 or at least how it's
designed but we can get into that but
thanks again for your youtube comments
and your twitter mentions we on GameSpot
you want to talk about the comments and
GameSpot yeah so I mean it was super
cool seeing all those comments because
they were very thorough very long and
very thorough we couldn't quite fit them
in this show because that would probably
take the full 10-15 minutes so we want
these to run for but still like thank
you for the support I knew it was like
it seemed rather constructive although I
didn't get to all of it it seemed like
people argued with debated with what you
said what other people said it's cool
it's cool to see that I'm sure there was
lots of [ __ ] posting too but yeah being
a Nintendo game and I think a lot of
like fanboy ISM came out but yeah thanks
so much for your well thought-out
comments and responses and critiques
we appreciate them but we're mainly
focusing on YouTube comments today we do
have a few that we picked out that we
thought were good questions things we
didn't touch on in the video
because unfortunately we don't always
have like 20 minutes to make we don't
want to have a 20 minute video so we
can't touch everything we wanted to but
you know wonder hit the main points in
our argument so yeah we've got a few
questions we'll alternate between
reading them and have Jake's power the
first one all right
the first one comes on YouTube and it's
from duck clock the clock actually he
says there's a bit of a debate going
around right now about breasts of the
wild weapon degradation system do you
think weapons break too easily or do you
think it provides an ideal challenge to
the player
you wanna start sure I can start I think
I I do have I have somewhat of an issue
with the degradation system I think
weapons break a little too easily I like
that they do break though because it
forces you to try different weapons it
forces you it kind of makes things tense
right it's like all right there's a
vocal in camp right there I've got an
almost broken sword can I get through
them I don't know so I really do like
that I just my I find a really cool
weapon and it breaks too soon and that's
kind of disappointing but I don't have a
huge issue with it I do think that like
a lot of things we went to the video the
weapon degradation factors into the
survival this game I think it encouraged
you to keep exploring this isn't like a
lute game it is it's there's loot
involved in this game so I think it's
not like diablo where you might get this
legendary weapon that you stick with for
three hours or something if you're like
a high level player and keep playing
another for the rest of the day and you
get a better one later on if you're you
don't have to worry about getting a
better one you have like the peak weapon
but I think in this game you always
unless you have the master sword which
still has like a limit on it I think
it's a certain amount of hits before you
have to like let it cool down you still
have to keep exploring and you get
excited when you see a new chest because
it could be any weapon you're not going
to get as attached to these weapons but
I think that factors in the survival you
know you're kind of living off the land
you're the fundamentals of this game are
based off of surviving and how this open
world is all about exploring and you
know making use of the wilderness I
think that the weapon degradation
encourages you to keep adapting and
being a resourceful link rather than
just as heroic one who charged in every
battle you know you might want to save
this bow for a later harder fight and I
think that factors into the game really
well and accentuates its advantages
shall we move on sure I think before
read this one yeah before we go to the
next big long question there's a comment
that I did find that I brought up here
you agree with I agreed with its by
expert he says had me until he said
breath the wild overshadows Witcher 3
and yes I've played both I I played both
as well it's really hard for me to say
that breath the wild overshadows Witcher
3 I know you were saying the open world
design only shadows Witcher 3 which I do
agree with but man mm-hmm i I don't yeah
I think I it's played which I think I
like which is three more than breast the
wild happening out you put a lot of
hours in the 800 witcher 3 eight hundred
or something a lot yeah you're on your
fourth playthrough yup and you platinum
day yeah no I
I believe I said like that was the part
of the video I knew people are gonna get
pissed off and I wasn't trying to piss
people off but it was my honest opinion
I think breath of the wild is a better
open-world game as an open-world game
than Metal Gear Solid 5 grand theft auto
v Witcher 3 I don't know that I would
call it a better game overall in The
Witcher 3 I think The Witcher 3 is very
very special I think that is the
pinnacle of triple-a development as we
know it now but I think
Zelda's open-world mechanics and how
they fit together and how they're all
integral I think is the best open-world
game but I don't think it's a better
game in The Witcher 3 maybe I maybe I
set to play it more before I decide that
but I think it's open-world mechanics
and systems have the way they overlap
are definitely better in The Witcher
threes so I stick by that so Jimena jadi
on youtube apologies I'm butchering your
name thank you for commenting though
have a couple of comments which we
appreciated I'll get right to the
question Mike I have a question what do
you think breath of the wild has done
for people who have never played a zelda
game how do you feel about this being
their introduction to the series is it
worth going back to the older games yes
it's worth going back to the older games
very much so Ocarina of Time link to the
past link between worlds and like the
Wind Waker they all still hold up really
well and I love all those games there
are some on the DS like Phantom
Hourglass and spirit tracks that I
wouldn't say you should waste too much
time with they're okay they're not
fantastic yes they're worth going back
to they hold up really well Majora's
Mask is my favorite game of all time let
alone just a Zelda game played out on
top jump and do though it's not as
accessible with a lot of them but they
all hold up really well still but I will
not say the press a while is a good
introduction to the Zelda series because
I mentioned the video that that's a
while kind of excuse a lot of the
formulas that we used to notice Ellie
and these eight dungeons with these
arbitrary items you
at the end this equipment that you learn
to use that will assist you throughout
the game to unlock new previously item
gated areas then you go flight the final
boss whether it's cannon or OGG annum or
whoever it happens to be breath the wild
is so different that I wouldn't actually
say this a good introduction to this
series but if you want to play this and
you like maybe two shrines the 3d
puzzles there or you liked the general
world itself's art direction or the kind
of a story of it like the actual
narrative and the divine beasts to RL so
these three-dimensional puzzles I think
if you like those parts a lot you will
like earlier zelda game so you haven't
played them specifically the ones I
mention Ocarina link between worlds Jake
you want to talk a little bit more about
link between worlds but this is a great
game but for different reasons and zelda
games are usually great games I would
say yes the older games are worth going
back to no this will not be the best
introduction to the series but as two
separate entities they're both very much
worth playing so like I said play this
game as much as you want because it's
awesome go back to the older games play
those because a lot of them are great
this would be our last question before
we teaser next episode Ryu shin X what
are both of your views and intend to
leveraging nostalgia to keep turning out
their first party games and does it play
a factor in your reviewing or playing of
games so I guess we didn't review this
yeah so preface we don't I used to
review games and I guess these reboot
kind of can be reviewing but we're not
scoring these games right we have
editors to do that here at GameSpot so
these aren't actual like the official
reviews but we have opinions on the game
but you know going into it if you
couldn't tell from the video i love
zelda i was wearing that stupid link cap
for the two camera segments but we until
you were shot we we both like Zelda I'm
a huge Delta fan but I think the great
thing about breath of the wild is that
you know you try to temper your
expectations going in despite a second
time as Olaf and I still can look at
them objectively I don't like Skyward
Sword at all I don't like Spirit Tracks
I don't like Phantom Hourglass that much
I could keep going on other ones I don't
like as much but I won't press awhile
it's awesome because I think it's
figured out what makes all the games
good like 3d puzzles be kind of the fact
that you know you can go underground
into these dungeons and your skills can
be challenged but then when you come
back up it's such a different game of
the overworld Hyrule Field isn't just
about
avoiding these skeletons at night
anymore or these preacher from the
Twilight Realm you're playing twilight
princess it's all about the land itself
being a character and it sounds so
cliche but it's very this very is like a
human versus environment stories not
just human versus human it's very it's
all about living off the land and I
think that's new for Zelda yeah I mean
it's funny she brings up nostalgic is
that is that is like very key and
Nintendo games at this point and there's
there's definitely nostalgia like I feel
a lot of nostalgia when I play breasts
of the wild but I don't necessarily
think that's why I like it so much
because I was actually telling you
earlier that like I mean a link between
worlds is almost all nostalgia right
like you basically revisit the area from
a Link to the Past v best Zelda game B
best 2d Zelda game all I'll give that
caveat so I think it's like you can't
ignore nostalgia when you're talking
about Zelda when you talk about Mario
but I think there's more to it like I
don't think we like this game because
it's a Zelda game yeah I don't think
Peter Brown gave it a 10 because it's a
Zelda game I don't think it is a 98 on
Metacritic because it's a Zelda game
he's actually a certain point was saying
that the Zelda aspects the narrative and
the kind of tone detracted from it oh
really he was saying at some point he
felt as if it could have been better
than he was and he told it yeah but they
would have never existed as annuity that
no way it wouldn't have been it wouldn't
have means that big it would have been
the biggest game yeah because it's the
biggest team Nintendo's ever had for a
game that wouldn't have the resource
bond if it was Elda but sometimes I
think it's cool because we get so tired
of these sequels in these retreads that
it's cool to see that Nintendo rather
than just pumping one out and using the
name to sell it and then okay it's an
alright game they used the name to allow
them to really take a risk and it's not
as bold as making a new IP but like you
they wouldn't have the resources a big
team they had so wasn't as le game so I
think they realized they could really do
something cool and different and really
happy they did yeah I think just like a
small little anecdote that kind of like
that kind of touches on the nostalgia is
that if you have the amiibos you can
scan them and occasionally a like cap of
the wind or like tunic of the wind will
drop and it's basically like links old
green tunic outfit ass
and I want those really bad I think I
have like the whole wind set or whatever
and I put them on and I'm like cool I
really wanted this but then I walk
around little bit I'm like but this
doesn't I don't think this fits my link
right now so I like the flame breaker
armor would suit me way better where I
am yeah exactly but as usual on the half
episodes as it were of reboot we're
going to tease our next episode Jake
what are we doing Mass Effect yes
Andromeda
yeah Messick Andromeda but not kind of
like what a lot of people have been
talking about they've been kind of
talking about how it isn't very good or
how doesn't live up to the to the hyper
expectations we're going to kind of take
a different approach a night we're going
to look at science fiction in general by
the time this goes up or beside the time
our Mass Effect episode goes up our
review will be at have been up for about
a week Scott Butterworth at GameSpot is
reviewing it so this again this won't be
the review but this will be our thoughts
about it and whether Mass Effect
Andromeda takes advantage of the fact
that you know it's in a brand new galaxy
and they could be doing a lot of cool
weird things with it and with the
characters and with the dialogue and
with the writing and then kind of look
at what other games future science
fiction games could you know look to or
you know look up to and use as influence
and yeah we're going to be like I said
the point of the show is to kind of look
at things differently so we're looking
forward to hopefully providing a
different opinion about Mass Effect
Andromeda you might see anywhere else so
we'll see you next week cool
[Music]